you have to know where to look
hidden in a block of flats behind a
bolted door this is what faith looks
like in China
soo-jung hai has run this underground
church in Beijing since 1989 he's been
to prison or re-education through labor
camps three times because of his beliefs
but these are the darkest days he's
known as the Chinese Communist Party
stamps down on any version of religion
that doesn't acknowledge its supremacy
aiya
what mother had told you the Lyotard
told you eat eat although coliseum at
alliant party hey go download watch
authority idea hey Dorothy what do you
know Bujji an uncanny adorable feel
China is officially an atheist state
with freedom of religion guaranteed in
the Constitution state sanctioned
churches do exist but the power and
glory belongs to the party it keeps
tight control worshipers are registered
CCTV cameras fitted and the Bible is
even being retranslated by the
government to ensure what they call
correct understanding but unofficial
churches were tolerated until recently
police closed this one by force in
Chengdu southwest China in December last
year this Beijing Church was also shut
down in another raid last year after its
leaders refused to install CCTV cameras
used to get throngs of worshippers
coming here is one of the biggest
underground churches in China and now
there's not much left to see we tried to
go in they said well there's nothing
here then we say what we wanted to see
they said the police have shut it down
and in any case the lift isn't stopping
at the third floor there's no trace left
and that's what people practicing
Christianity in China fear they'll
simply be scrubbed from existence and in
March this year another famous church
with the congregation a thousand people
strong was banned afterwards they
pledged to hold a prayer meeting in a
public square in Beijing we also went
but the square was simply shut down by
authorities the few brave enough to come
here were quietly escorted away
undercover police officers followed us
while we filmed then approached I saw
it's not good why a police station
opposite pasta shoes home Church he says
it was built to keep watch over him
everyone exists in a state of paranoia
the faithful worried for their liberty
but also the communist party itself
which sees threats everywhere even here
and persist they will but only as long
as the party less than Tom Cheshire Sky
News Beijing